Você acorda parecendo que foi atropelado
por um caminhão mesmo depois de dormir 8
horas seguidas. E o pior, seu médico ou
médica olha os seus exames e diz: "Tá
tudo normal, deve ser estress."
Presta atenção. O estudo de 2023 ligou a
fadiga inexplicável a reativação de
vírus que você pegou, ó, há anos como e
tem bar que 95% dos adultos carregam no
corpo. Eles não foram embora, eles
estavam dormindo, ou melhor, estavam. Se
você tem dor no corpo, brain fog ou
nerva mental e esse cansaço que não
passa, pode não ser depressão, pode ser
uma inflamação viral silenciosa. Nos
próximos minutos eu vou te passar a
tríade nutricional exata que eu uso na
minha clínica para ajudar o seu corpo a
colocar esses vírus de volta na jaula.
Pessoal, vamos conversar sério aqui. Na
visão integrativa, a gente entende que
ter o vírus no corpo é diferente estar
doente. Pensa num vírus da EPS ou da
mononucleose. O EPS tem bar, eles são
como se fosse um dragão adormecido. Todo
mundo tem. O problema não é o dragão
existir, é o dragão acordar. Na medicina
ortodoxa convencional, a gente aprende a
tratar infecção aguda. Sabe quando você
tem aquela febre de 39º, a garganta
doendo, o inchado? Isso é fácil de ver,
mas o que ninguém te conta é sobre a
infecção latente reativada. É aquele
estado onde você não está doente o
suficiente para ser internado ou
internada, mas não tem energia para
viver. É o chove não molha da imunidade.
E por que que isso acontece? Aqui entra
a ciência que os exames de rotina não
mostram. Vírus são parasitas
intracelulares obrigatórios. E o que que
isso significa? Que eles não têm
dinheiro para pagar a conta de luz. Eles
precisam roubar sua energia. Então eles
sequestram as suas mitocôndrias. Lembra
da aula de biologia? Mitocôndria é
aquela usina de energia da célula.
Quando o vírus reativa, seja por
estresse, pós-covid ou uma alimentação,
ele desvia o ATP, que é a sua energia,
para fabricar cópias dele mesmo. E qual
é o resultado? Seu sistema imune fica em
alerta constante, gastando energia para
vigiar o inimigo e sobra zero para você
trabalhar, treinar ou brincar com seus
filhos. É uma bateria viciada biológica.
E o erro número um que eu vejo é gente
tomando café estimulante o tempo todo
para acordar, quando na verdade deveriam
estar modulando a carga viral. Então,
como que a gente resolve isso na prática
com segurança e sem remédios pesados?
Anota aí, hein? Isso é muito importante.
Vale ouro. Passo número um, a relação
lisina e arginina. Vírus, especialmente
os da família EPS, como é o caso do
Epistem Bar, precisam de homeno chamado
arginina para se replicar. Se você está
em crise comendo chocolate, amendoim,
noes e castanhas todo dia, você está
dando combustível premium para o vírus.
Então, qualquer ação em momentos de
crise, reduza esses alimentos ricos em
agina. Qual que é o suporte necessário?
aumente o consumo de lisina e compete
com a arginina e atrapalha a replicação
viral. Em alguns casos, é muito
importante usar a suplementação de
alelisina. Eu uso o tempo todo no meu
consultório, mas sempre com orientação
profissional. Passo dois, romper a capa
do vírus. Muitos desses vírus têm uma
capa de gordura que nós chamamos na
medicina de envelope lipídico. Existe um
ácido gráso derivado do coco chamado
monolaurina que vem do ácido láurico.
Estudos invitro sugerem que ele ajuda a
desestabilizar essa capa protetora do
vírus sem agredir as suas células. É uma
ferramenta fantástica de suporte
imunológico que pouca gente sabe ou usa.
Passo três, que é o escudo mitocondrial.
Se o vírus rouba energia e gera
oxidação, você precisa de antioxidantes
específicos. O NAC Netcistina ajuda a
fazer a gluta o nosso faxineiro master
do organismo, zinco e vitamina C, o
clássico que funciona mais nas doses
certas para manter a barreira
imunológica alta. Vitamina D de dado. Se
a sua vitamina D está abaixo de 40 ou
50, seu sistema imune está lutando com
uma mão amarrada nas costas. Agora, o
pulo do gato. Nada disso funciona se
você estiver banhado em cortisol. O
cortisol, que é hormônio do estresse, é
o sinal químico que o vírus espera para
acordar. Sabe aquela afita que aparece
quando você tá nervoso ou nervosa?
Exatamente isso. Reativação viral por
estresse. Não adianta tomar o suplemento
mais caro se você não dormir antes das
23 horas e não gerenciar o seu estresse.
O sono é o momento em que o sistema
linfático limpa o lixo do cérebro e o
sistema imune faz a ronda. Então, se
você tem fadiga crônica, pare de buscar
uma pílula mágica para dar energia. O
segredo pode ser parar de ter sua
energia roubada por hóspedes
indesejados. Comece ajustando a dieta.
menos agina, mais lisina e cuidando do
intestino. Mas atenção, essa é a ponta
do iceberg, as dosagens exatas e como
combinar isso com outros fitoterápicos
depende de cada caso. Saia do vídeo
agora se você gosta de ficar no
superficial. Eu vou te contar uma
verdade conveniente. O YouTube e os
conselhos aqui me limitam. Aqui eu
preciso simplificar, censurar dosagens,
omitir protocolos controversos. Na
comunidade fechada não tem esse filtro.
Eu compartilho os exatos protocolos que
eu uso na minha clínica, casos de
reversão que parecem possíveis,
combinações off que funcionam e
fornecedores confiáveis, além de
interpretação avançado de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Nós temos
lives semanais respondendo perguntas,
PDF com 47 protocolos exclusivos, grupo
no WhatsApp, fantástico. Se você quer a
visão funcional real, sem simplificação
para as massas, clica aqui em seja
membro. E não é para curiosos, não é
para pessoas comuns, é para quem quer
resultados. Agora, se você quer ir ainda
mais fundo, existe o nível dois. A cada
duas semanas, fazemos lives de imersão
total com 2 horas de duração, desse
artigos científicos linha por linha e
debatendo controvérsia que ninguém ousa
tocar, revelando os bastidores das
pesquisas que a indústria não quer que
você entenda. E tem mais, seu nome será
mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. Você se torna a parte
visível dessa comunidade elite que está
reescrevendo as regras da medicina.
Enquanto a maioria dorme e assiste
passivamente, você estará ao meu lado
construindo um conhecimento de verdade,
tendo o seu reconhecimento público como
alguém que investe no que realmente
importa. Não é só sobre aprender, é
sobre pertencer ao círculo interno de
quem está mudando o jogo. Poucos têm
essa coragem. Você tem? Agradecimentos
aos nossos queridos membros no grupos
avançados de estudos. Cláudia Leitão,
Alex Caldas, Ana Paula Vascular, José
Fortunato Mtinho, FS Machado RJ, Sou
Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril,
Estela Mares, Elô Terapias Integrativas,
Saúde Lães da Doença. Muito obrigado
pelo seu carinho e pelo seu apoio.